so we get an x-ray me a traitor
an expert are what happens if we've lost
a nut or a bolt and it's falling in one
of these Jesus and can we just forget
about that for now or do we have to go
on are we don't know we're doing it
properly every yeah no but there's no
nuts involved there at the end of the
day we don't have one of their majesties
prisons we have systems that we have to
go by no matter who is for we do not
change the citizens for anybody else
there was that trolley nearby just
coming doll thank you pizza boxes so all
the [ __ ] work has gone in so it's
time to make my escape aided and abetted
by prison head chef my accomplice dal
Hatfield
they'll be brilliant this is crazy
another this is absolutely ludicrous
check there's no faults and nuts and
guns and doubt then - laughs show some
flexibility go to supermarkets but
enough but [ __ ] me this is ridiculous
this takes the biscuit and if every
single cake and tartar has to be x-rayed
I'm going through two
[Music]
morning two more doors to go - were out
man the logistics logistics bloody hell
there's times like this you really do
know you're in a prison yella about time
Dino Dino come through reverse up please
oh Jesus Christ on my clothing come on
come on go then
honestly we're doing in there see you
later
it's been x-rayed sir yeah man down I'm
going to explain sir
with my shop opening in half an hour
it'd be quicker to tunnel our way out
[Music]
treat the tarts out there
[Music]
[Music]
so amazing how good the food looks
outside the prison I mean it's
extraordinary listen we may be in a
pop-up but yeah I mean I'm I'm hoping
this stuff goes look at it
hello welcome what comes it what can I
get you amazing lemon curtains actually
made by the local bricks prison and I
hear that you're working with my son
your son yes Jerome Samuels and his
mother my god when he focuses he puts
his head down and he gets stuck in but
from little he's always he's always like
looking in the kitchen everything I just
think he's just mixed the wrong company
right is really usable you know yeah I
walked in this morning bad news he's
been suspended
there's some verbal abuse giving her me
officers give us a bit of a kick I know
that that person he's in the course you
know he's focusing what was that so
where to see him that's something I
don't really do do you not think he
needs to see Wade speak to me all the
time he can write to me it's not
somewhere that I would like to be on a
regular basis no it's not that
this time he was thank you for coming I
appreciate it any message for him I mean
I get himself together yeah I was
worried that people wouldn't want to eat
prison made food but the bad boys bakery
name seems to be pulling in the punters
[Music]
very crazy on there and how does about
you feel about mate what prisons like
last cool one that's all I did yeah
that's cool
it doesn't put you off your stuff thank
you so much can only be a good thing
well try and give them some chances and
I think you know life's a learning curve
and if they can come in there and
educate themself and learning skills